it's still difficult for those fever to
come back here he was 16 when he landed
in the Yugen vehicle torgul a
correctional facility for children the
authorities considered especially
intractable the uncle of T of Amitabh
late arriving here was like arriving in
hell only it didn't smell like smoke
there was just deathly silence like in a
morgue liking show horse today when they
were walked around the exhibition in the
former facility the memories come
rushing back between 1964 and 1989 over
four thousand youths were locked up in
torg arm baber got sentia after he tried
to run away from a home he'd been placed
in for the info NIM your Finland wha I
just wanted peace to not have to work in
a factory at 6am I didn't want to hear
any orders to go clean a room or go eat
I was working soon as lion I just wanted
to be a person with what I to sit on a
rock or in a tree to just be left in
peace nice la Rosa whoa whoa but vapor
didn't find peace at the youth detention
center his daily routine consisted of
hours of monotonous work for the metal
industry excessive hours of sports and
military drills he believes he was sent
to a correctional facility because his
parents weren't loyal enough to the
government in torg ow any sign of
resistance were severely punished the
worst was solitary confinement in the
basement
and in August to end up in these cells
meant facing the possibility that you'd
never emerge with a healthy body and
soul again because he only ended up down
here when they wanted to beat you up the
same for if the screams from here
couldn't be heard outside improving you
not really feeling up cause get honest
the four months he spent in torgul
effect Ralph Faber to this day he first
told his daughter the story when a
newspaper wrote an article about him
our boys 10 minutes and i sent the paper
down in front of her and told her to
read it and then we talk what the hell
mothers don't want us and then we forced
ourselves to get through it and just
like now there was a lot of crying and
then we talked about it God was thin and
then GOP's available
talking about it as well as having the
story made public is as important to
Viva as reparations but at the same time
he knows that no one can give him back
his lost childhood not even 25 years
after reunification